after all these years
i've discovered the source of ultimate
power
face it you'll never catch me
it's gonna be back in blue
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
are you being reckless don't worry
nobody's gonna get hurt
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i've discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
hope i'm not too late
i'm sorry who are you memes tales okay
this is what we're gonna do step one
light taunting step two i have no idea
that wasn't too bad
today's forecast calls for a 100
chance of adventure
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
[Music]
you